bonsoir comme vous pouvez le voir et
m'ont l'hiver s'est fait couper la barbe
il a rajeuni a été faire une cure je ne
sais plus où non je plaisante bien sûr
vous l'avez deviné g à côté de moi un
charmant cuisinier qui vient de
remporter un grand prix
oui le prix prosper montagné qui est
considéré comme le prix goncourt de la
cuisine je crois que sur ce monsieur
elle s'appelle guy legay et il a
remporté ce prix pourquoi je suis
qu'avez vous fait vous le mettez nous
avions l'arrière de procéder à faire
avec quatre gars l'étude et en plat de
pâtes alimentaires avec un plat de pâtes
alimentaires ça a je crois vraiment les
verts auraient été collé parce qu'il
sait pas faire les plats qui vous l'a
pas dit mais tu as dit on en reparlera
tout allait vraiment que pensez vous de
ce prix et bien j'en passe vous pouvez
bien c'est un prix qui est donné tous
les ans comme le goncourt d'ailleurs qui
sait peut-être la seule chose qui est
très couru bien en ce sens qu'il était
difficile obtenait sa qualité
la fatalité le très fermé il faut penser
monsieur guy legay l'a vraiment mérité
ouais je suis obligé de te dit penser
puisque je faisais partie autochtone ce
jury qui de l'année
alors aujourd'hui voyez vous je passe à
côté lorsque j'allais dire alors
monsieur longuet si vous le voulez
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement vous
allez passer de l'autre côté vous pouvez
retirer de même presque votre comment ça
s'appelle jamais rien puisqu'il va plus
ce qu'il a pu être cuisinier pendant
qu'il va être président du jury
lorsque le saint sacrement passe les
cuisiniers et vous allez avoir à juger
aujourd'hui le coton cochon de lait
farci que l'on attend d'eux alors le
cochon de lait farci que va réaliser
raymond univers vous viendrez tout
allait il viendra nous dire ce que vous
en pensez très honnêtement bien ce bien
monsieur part si vous voulez vous
retirez par ici vous de façon à bien
voir vous verrez très bien ne l'ont pas
tout faire et on va faire une porte
asseyez vous commencez déjà vous des
bananes et non mais c'est le temps qu'il
va nous falloir 4g c'est bien je suis en
repos en rognant de porc enfin
au départ une partie seulement combien
vous infotiv alors là ça va très bien je
vais faire mon cas personnes - quatre
personnes
alors je prends les quantités
nécessaires pour quatre personnes
mais suffisante mais c'est insuffisant
quand vous dites voilà alors coupé en
cubes réguliers ou alors la cervelle va
servir tout à l'heure pour une autre
apparition à non regardez alors ici le
foie bon ça vous êtes vite peuvent être
gardés par un prix prosper montagné
pourquoi ne serais-je pas moi intimidées
alors que lui il était tout à l'heure
profondément avoir à passer non plus
devant un jury et parce que devant le
jury n'était pas impressionné lorsqu'il
était à son affaire il savait ce qu'il
ait fait ça exactement on fait tout de
même il y avait peut-être le trac aussi
l'espérance en prix alors ici voyez vous
on peut paraît également quelqu'un gagne
en affirmant fois je forçais ce soit
seulement de grave c'est ça alors ici
l'excellent de rognons aussi des
champions de paris et où comme ceux-ci
guy groux oui c'est bien les gros
puisque nous avons cherché à faire des
choix vous coupez grossièrement aussi
fortement
enfin fait pas du tout petit morceau de
champignons calme aujourd'hui je suis
comme un c'est parfait alors ici du
l'art l'art comment le lard de poitrine
des 100 g aigle légèrement salée il en
faudrait 100 grammes mais légèrement
salée j'espère que nos téléspectatrices
ont leurs petits papiers à 900 grammes
en fait une autre tranche de survivants
cela vous avez 200 g vous êtes comme
avec notre américaine vous prenez pas de
balance pour autant à ça je ne prendrai
pas la balance pour autant là alors je
m'en remets ici très chaud une poêle
dans laquelle je vais mettre du cndd ou
voilà qui est fait quelle quantité de
sel ou au camp mais 52 grammes environ
la maximum c'est ça ça va chauffer
pendant je vais couper votre là mais là
le la bombe la veille le lard pardon
c'est vrai défaut
c'est un défaut que j'ai aussi sont
prises le monde s'ennuie toujours je
m'étais investi au pied dans la marmite
l'instant cela arrivait bien vous prenez
un agent à vous invitez vos petons bon
alors tout ça je m'en vais le salé le
poivre et alors le sel est ici le voilà
ou alors ça c'est très méthode culinaire
alors les cuisiniers salle sur la
planche comme ça tu vas y remet un tout
qui sait quoi faire je lis aussi je
donne annoncé pour faire passer le seul
dans la totalité des surfaces pour le
toi même s'ils font pareil voilà la
personne ne leur dit raymond à ses
efforts ceux qui veulent les cuisiniers
s'ils font exactement ce qu'ils veulent
un bien trop vous aviez plus vous n'en
avez pas eu tant que ça n'est ce pas non
il a fait signe que non le mot con alors
la voyez vous c'est touchant un cochon
de lait farci c'est du poivre farci aux
cochons de lait bon ça va
moi j'essaie de voir sur le tableau
combien yat sen d'où je parle comme une
famille j'aurais pu mettre ce secteur
formule de pharmacien habituel se
suffisait ce bond alors vous en mettez
clef s hydrater les 150 g de pois 150 g
de est reparti réunion aéro je vais bien
séparer les lents dans des zones
désormais repartir chacun des éléments
car ceux ci ce sont les éléments
nécessaires pour la brochette de stars
le derrière d'agneau pour le dernier à
nyon de port pour parler une langue est
un peu réveillée elle mettait très
français dans l'appel 5q de sport le
sport français
alors lui il est dans le four messi et
du bordelais si porcelets et auxerre les
envoyer là je vais donner ce qu'on
appelle un tour fois le poisson à saisir
tous les éléments à les réduire pour
envoyer encore mobilisés est-ce qu'il
faut que ça prenne couler et pour qu'ils
prennent aux couleurs et il faut qu'il
soit effectivement légèrement doré
défaut d'accord avec neige il sait
parfaitement doser plomb soit la
décharge col celui là est temps que
celui de devant est un peu plus chaud
j'ai en même temps je veux un peu trop
vite je consens d'agen parce que c'est
fini vous comment et quand le moment
était fait j'ai dit tiens je résume je
résume exécuté
je dois vous laisser longtemps n'ont pas
tellement longtemps
je m'en vais finir de données la
coloration par tous ces morceaux si
c'est brouillon je tends l'oreille notre
gagnant oui non on pourra en parler
pendant que gelée pendant que j'ai
réalisé les brochettes un petit moment
il vous plaira pas l'achever les
brochettes et bien à ce stand temps mort
et là vous parlais de la gagnant notre
concours ya eu un castrais passaient
leur set que j'ai failli fermer
d'ailleurs qui va quand même pas se
regarder
il y a des na li similitudes une
émission en suspens notre
téléspectatrice
bon alors là voyez vous je peux écouter
et je vais d'ailleurs et vous pourrez
goûter vous pourquoi je viens pour
écouter et montre une façon pour soir
durant attendu vous avez un super départ
8 août afin d'asseoir ça n'a pas
d'importance tout sur un champignon et
puis je m'en vais mais attention là
comment on doit jouer vos champignons
j'étais mauvaise sont réfugiés donc
voilà alors ça c'est terminé pour le
moment oui il vaut mieux dégraisser
parce que je ne veux pas tout à l'heure
pour fabriquer mais coquette ça sera
beaucoup plus facile maintenant je vais
fabriquer les suberaies alors le sujet
le rotor autrefois on savait il y avait
des bruits que tout autour du foyer et
de temps en temps je faisais des petits
pâtés comme faisait cuire sur la brique
alors on les appelait sur brick & spa et
puis petit à petit il a eu une
déformation du mot et on est arrivé a su
briques
c'est d'ailleurs il faut bien
reconnaître que c'est un mot que l'on a
oublié même dans le langage est
cuisinier les cuisiniers ne l'utilisent
pour ainsi dire plus et pourtant c'est
on a raison de revenir à des formules
c'est pourquoi je vous disais dans la
dernière émission que ce serait une
émission qui serait doublement française
en effet il s'agit d'un prix culinaire
strictement français et il s'agit d'une
recette éminemment
française alors là nous avons alors jury
enfin des membres du jury avait composé
le thème et c'était aux ouvriers à
l'exécuter allons ici il s'agit de
muscade
alors voyez vous je muscade 7 server que
tu va nous couper en dés et les
cyclistes est cuit alors un peu de
muscade papillons mâles de peur
également une salle de sport alors ici
dufoir pas trop pas trop ici un peu
d'eux un petit peu de sauce béchamel
très serré renvoyer la profession de
cuisinier jean ils ont l'habitude de
quand il faudra sauce béchamel disant
confortés qu'ils font n'est ce pas en
réalité la trouille de cuillères à soupe
alors une à 9
on a fait là aussi c'est presque c'est
parce que beaucoup d'ailleurs je lui
servais la muscade le poivre et une
cuillère est de chamelle 9 alors il ya
encore autre chose là qui voyons voyons
ici ce panneau là alors il y à une
cervelle de porc ébouillanté un enfant
tier 2 cuillères de crème fait c'est ça
et les kurdes comme frêche est bon grâce
à cette recette
voilà qui est fait et puis le cuillère
en bois
celle qui l'avait laissé brûler l'autre
jour si si gentiment il n'y a jamais une
caisse elle aussi bonne cuisine c'est
vrai je suis assis vous là alors je vais
mélanger tout ça alors cervelle craie
redite le voyez vous n'en avez pas
cervelle crème sauce béchamel f muscade
sel et poivre à la région tient ici une
une sorte de crème dans laquelle nage
les petits morceaux et ingrédients
alors si vous voulez bien alain les
écraser pas vous mélangez simplement non
je m'élance simplement
alors pendant si vous voulez bien qu'à
three vous allez parler de notre gagnant
pendant
commencée en gros chez les brochets et
bien notre gagnant que nous avons fait à
temps qui remporte le jeu de harry magie
de la cuisine et madame galets madame j
galets sais pas quel est son prénom qui
avait tu dises qui habite 17 rue des des
rôles je crois d'abord dans le 21
vous avez 21 bonne dit dans une belle
région sénat mais c'est une année le 25e
c'était une très très bonne année aux
départements avant on nous donne la
recette du foie de veau lazarini alors
ne l'ont pas la donner mais là vous la
félicitons vous mettez ça dans vos
archives et dans vos réserves
particulière à l'envoyer au ici nous
alternons un champ du lundi quand un
morceau de foie en morceaux de comme on
irait leurs oignons en marche au delà
des spas champignons ont commencé on
finit par le champignon par mais si vous
vous trompez une fois dans notre camp
alors si je me trompe et le poids dans
l'eau voilà on fait un cas comme ça
alors c'est évidemment un peu fastidieux
mais enfin on va essayer d'aller
chercher vite commencé féliciter madame
galets parce que tout cela c'est vrai je
devrais la féliciter j'aurais pu la
publicité déjà et bien je le fais bien
volontiers s'avère si c'est vous qui
avez choisi ce bien sûr j'aimerais bien
l'homme avait voulu se féliciter non
mais alors félicité là puisque vous
l'avez sélectionné alors je fais aussi
du mal à égaler parce que absorbé parce
que je suis cramé choisir je crois vous
vous êtes laissé séduire aussi par la
région bonne cette api qui vous plaît à
peu au combien et bien bravo madame
galets et je pense que vous êtes en
train de noter la recette des brochettes
que raymond ni deux et vous notez bien
un morceau de la un morceau de
champignons un morceau de foie en marche
au trognon et ça c'est là où je suis
tellement absorbé liste comprend la
renommée de l'art et la manière la cchl
l'art et la manière
il n'y a pas de magie
puis mettez ce qui vous plaît avec toute
façon les brochettes seront appréciées
par kylie dégustera tout j'en suis
certaine alors ces derniers gagnent un
tout petit peu plus et tout à l'heure ne
s'est pas maintenant qu'on appelle les
quantités non tout à l'heure on va
d'abord faire les brochettes effet agir
il faut l'évacuer alors vous savez elles
sont juste saisi ça ne paraisse en
suisse
vous avez juste faire venir dans un peu
de sa douce et fraîche à tous et tous
pour ceux qui l'auront réduire en puis
j'avais enlever le gras
j'en ai entendu tout le gras qui
descendront ja rule eux maintenant des
justement des divers ingrédients surtout
dire voilà je viens voir l'arc 4
brochette tressé ça ça j'aurais pu
charger un tout petit peu plus j'aurais
dû charger un tout petit peu plus bon eh
bien maintenant nous allons les passer
la bande à savoir la manière de me
donner une âme une assiette
il vous aurait fallu alors c4 wallon les
passer d'abord avec 4 cuillères de
moutarde forte profession est important
les enveloppes presque on est en retard
on l'espère la hauteur de fortin ah oui
moteurs de forte d'ailleurs bon on ne
sait pas très loin de dijon
mr à cette recette là qui viennent bonne
non enfin puisque nous parlions de fonds
alors ici nous pouvons utiliser du père
carif île pour utiliser à nouveau du
sein nous si nous voulons bouger un
mouchoir
eh bien je vais utiliser du beurre
pour la main alors je vais tout faire et
puis maintenant evous ici
voilà d'un mythe alors si je verrai
assaisonner un tout petit peu parce que
tout de même on perd toujours une partie
de la saison demain en il en est resté
beaucoup là dessus tout à fait oui il en
reste un petit peu se rappelant le
gaspiller le poivre la nord assaisonner
un tout petit peur voilà qui est fait et
puis le ballon allait passer comme ceux
ci à la mi temps
voyez vous c'est pas toujours très c'est
un peu péjoratif quelquefois à quand on
dit quelque chose et à la mi temps c'est
pas très flatteur mais là en
l'occurrence salaires faibles mais en
plus j'ai pas le cas excusez moi du coin
de l'oeil je guette votre cuisinier prix
goncourt c'est pas mon cuisinier de mes
cousines celui que vous et vos compères
et il ne s'est pas une 1ère très
attentifs sais pas si je dois
interpréter ces petits coups à fond et
bien voilà c'est prêt eh bien nous
allons mettre tout de suite les brochets
accueillir dans mes mains dans le beurre
on va les retourner
et puis on va surtout très déçu andré
pas question de faire une annonce que
vous pas du tout farine cordon alors si
vous voulez suivre et à votre budget
avec ça c'est très difficile à faire
non ni ceux ci l'ont fait alors
[Musique]
je sais je sais il est silencieux parce
que tous eu un trac fou de bassan là je
vais retourner les lèvres est tombée les
aurait bousillés là et offre d'autant
qu'il est ici par contre là nous
revenons pour les suivre et alors pas
trop chaud non plus assedic en feu moyen
et qu'est ce que vous mettez là du sein
doute alors je vais du comité des
affaires ici c'est à dire du beurre que
l'on a débarrassé de ses impuretés
alors je vais les chauffer et pour
faciliter l'opération bien que ce ne
soit pas très orthodoxe je vais ajouter
un petit peu de mie de pain de façon à
avoir déçu bray plus facile à mouler
est-ce que sirigu c'est régulier c'est à
dire que nous devons nous avons à la
répétition eu des difficultés pour au
fait assez subrip avec si elle en six
petites quantités alors nous avons pensé
que le meilleur moyen de pallier et et 2
mètres en deux mi temps ce qui ne ce qui
facilite un peu l'opération avec qui
laquelle reste quand même difficile
alors c'est pourquoi nous allons ne pas
prendre de risques exagérés et nous
allons essayer de faire
je n'ai plus
je suis voilà qu'est ce qui se passe au
point de vue tant au point de vue tant
il vous reste 7 minutes des petits
paquets comme ceux que l on creuse dans
la fois les petits paquets dans lesquels
il y a rappelé de nous alors de la
cervelle de leurs muscles ça va nous
allons justement les occidentaux peur
c'était à chaud sans plus rien
moi je n'aurais petit commence que
maintenant alors il y a de la sorte
béchamel de la crème du cercle du
pouvoir de la musique hard
il y à du de la serveurs et c'est tout
c'est ça voilà un déficit non à la vente
iront bien sûr je n'ai pas dit au départ
que je sers excusez moi je dis on
n'avait pas bien là nous avons résumé je
vais aller chercher une petite partie
parce que cela me paraît bien droit
chercher si si ça nous avait caché sous
la table
c'est une fois son talent et ses
suppliques se servent en même temps en
même temps à l'envoyer au alors c'est et
c'était très joli sorte dessins sur
effectivement sur la brique du foyer on
comprend très bien que ça va se passer
très facilement il un fou du un peu d'où
les constant parce que j'étais trop bien
mieux comment ont-ils fait les élèves
qui sont très bien le maître cuisinier
qui s'enlise alors beaucoup les ans et
och et dans des petits moules
ils ont dix ans leur est fortement des
moules avec du beurre super clarifier à
cette ville andry des femmes et les
hommes moulée dans des petits moules qui
était réfugié est très joli et plus à
éviter les dangers de la cuisson à la
poêle qui tout de même le reste s'est
désagrégé un petit prix
alors voyez où la loi il n'y a pas de
problème la raison qu'ils sont très très
beau feuilleton qui disent il faut pas
qu'ils tissent trop vite alors là on
sort les titres très joli chahut ya eu
des présentations moi je vous le savez à
faire si je n'aime pas tellement les
décors de carton le décor n'aime pas les
riches les architectures et c'est
pourquoi en fait je me colle
architecture capitalisation actuelle
mais en cuisine vous voulez que ce soir
est toujours refaire parce que non je
veux que ça se discute mais j'ai
toujours peur que l'on ne perde un temps
précieux qui consiste à avoir une
cuisine
quelle qualité au bénéfice d'un décor
tir qui lui le mondial n'a pas grand
chose à faire
en définitive à ce qui concerne des
études site ont dit nos listes fitou et
ou alors on le regarde et tout est froid
quand on le canton le détail on est bien
là catherine je crois que
nous avons terminé nous avons terminé
heureusement car oui mais je rêvais d'un
des quatre minutes
alors les brochets mon dieu je parce
qu'elles sont cuites
nous allons les retourner second
entraînement oui oui c'est très bien le
son qui fait d'elle regardez comme un
sport je pense que ça doit être même un
peu trop dorée pour la caméra
[Musique]
alors voilà le derrière pour challes et
sa diffusion
c'est à dire on l'a farsi comme vous
allez pouvoir le voir on a pas reçus
avec une farce de porc d'ailleurs mis de
pain et une partie des intérieurs et de
la viande du devant c'est à dire la
viande le tout tout tout les épaules et
les côtelettes ont servi à faire la
farce à laquelle on a mis beaucoup fines
herbes et de la mitre ça me fait jouer
de grands rôles cette recette c'est à
dire que je pense qu il ya la 2g deux
vocations par vocation
j'ai deux intentions dans cette de
propos dans cette émission
d'abord présenter un plat très français
qui tout compte fait rien avant très
gros succès puisqu'il s'agit d'un prix
culinaire et deuxièmement une idée de
présentation qui je crois va vous plaire
alors qui est celle du du g l'oréal a
d'ailleurs je n'interviens absolument
pas cela reproduit alors voyez vous il
appliqué ici on devrait faire interner
il appliqué ici c'est
recherche un petit peu comme l'antique
que des vendeurs et des sports alors là
vous êtes rappeler que vous étiez déjà
je savais que j'étais du sud-ouest et
aficionado bien je vais demander à
monsieur guy legay de se rapprocher
simplement pour qu'ils voient de plus
près ce que vous faites non vous y voyez
un inconvénient niveau jusque là nous
allons accueillir mais rassurez vous on
ne vous fera pas travailler aujourd'hui
vous est ce que ces départs est
satisfaisant c'est très bien laurent
mercier je crois que vous ne représentez
ça irait bien d'autres choses il y avait
beaucoup de choses autour
est ce qu'il y avait monsieur faits
décrits pinette de l'orgue deux fois
enfin du bruit comme quoi un parc est en
fait état de charges jolie vous voyez
vraiment qu'ils n'étaient pas votre
propos aujourd'hui bien sûr puisque déjà
je crois que là nous allons voir combien
de temps vous avez joué nous avions
trois heures trois heures mais comprenez
vraiment baroin lui pardonnant violence
dessus le marché
et j'avais le droit d'amener certains
éléments déjà cuit alors demandé qu'on
fait remarquer que vous avez
pratiquement amené le porcelet ou qui
sont passionnés le porcelet sept ans
porte les attend s'ils voulaient voilà
alors il ya de la sauce qu'elle avait
amené cuir et m'en voudrais que nos
téléspectateurs ce qu'on chasse sur les
détails le détail de ce que contient
cette recette
ça me paraît très utile parce que sans
ça je crois qu'il ne se rappelleront pas
tout alors pour ceux pour faire cette
recette ils auront besoin au départ de
150 g de foie de porc 250 g rien de porc
aussi 200 g de lard de poitrine
vous avez dit qu'il fallait qu'ils
soient bien maigre j'ai dit que de
préférence il valait mieux qu'ils soient
mais les jours
josef jung est d'accord c'est chez lui
des lotissements mois 100 g de
champignons de paris du sade ou du sel
du poivre sur heavy en quelle quantité
ainsi que de la muscade d'ailleurs qu'à
4 cuillerées de moutarde forte que vous
avez bien dont vous avez bien enveloppé
vos brochettes 4 cuillérées de fleurs de
thym 4 cuillerées de mie de pain où
l'avez-vous mise la fleur de table avec
les brochettes sur les brochettes bien
très bien
et puis les subs rica lors une cervelle
de porc c'est bien ça n'est ce pas
ébouillanté un oeuf entier une cuillère
de crème fraîche une cuillère de
béchamel vous vous en avez apporté car
prison hier j sel du poivre de laruscade
et du beurre clarifié nos réponses vous
affaler page et me sonné le réveil un
tout petit peu en avance car je sais la
seconde nécessaire à la récupération nos
esprits exactement
bon et bien eu raison de votre maison de
cette recette médiation nous allons
remercier monsieur pas le remercier à
lui d'abord d'avoir réussi à gagner ce
prix important c'est ensuite avoir eu la
gentillesse de venir nous voir
aujourd'hui est de présenter lui-même
qu'est ce qui lui assure un plant esprit
d'après vous qu'est ce qu'il avait fait
de mieux que les autres
eh bien d'abord il a eu l'idée aussi non
non moi je crois d'abord qu'il a eu une
idée merveilleuse c'est de présenter son
le porcelet avec la peau croustillante
avec une force extrêmement bonne facile
à manger parce qu'il a coupé et cetera
et puis que dans la scène dans le fait
de présenter d'abord sa présentation
était jolie cesser ces brochettes
vous avez dit qu'il ne fallait pas y
attacher une importance non je ne sais
pas à la présentation qu'on peut
attacher une importance capitale
enfin tout ça c'était très bon les subs
rick était très bon ses petites copines
et de langues est bonne et l'ensemble
était vraiment très très bien servi
savait faire cuire les pâtes et ils
savaient que faire à cuire les pâtes et
alors forcément il avait même fait
l'essai par lui-même sinon il va effet
n'est pas de couleur différente c'est
très joli vous savez c'était très joli
mais là c'était très important
alors quand même que vous ne pouvez pas
renier ce plat qui n'ont ce biais d'un
complet par rapport vous les enfants
quand pensez-vous live ou par les airs
oui monsieur olivennes serait un
concurrent dangereux
on en reparlera une autre année dans une
dizaine d'années
pour l'instant nous allons laisser nos
téléspectateurs avec leurs porcelets
farsi après tout pourquoi pas leur
cochon de lait farci avec leurs
banderilles avec les subs rick avec tout
ça qui est vraiment jolie et pas très
bien mais il a regardé pour la caméra la
même idéologie mangez pas trop rester
calmes alors voilà et bien raymond soyez
remerciés à vous de dire ainsi qu à vous
monsieur le gué de dire bon appétit et
de téléspectateurs dit le volet vous
voilà fethi bon appétit à tous pas
d'ironie raymond
[Musique]